[Music]
hey there and welcome back and i'd like
to do a bonus lesson this week and the
bonus lesson i'm gonna do is
animating so let's animate this
uh style frame and let's make it uh
into something interesting so how would
i do that well the first thing i would
do is i'm looking at
this and i'm saying okay it's 30 frames
a second it's 91 so it's three seconds
long it's too short for me let's make it
uh 300 frames so it's about 10 seconds i
like to make a lot of things around 10
seconds in length if i'm just making
something to make something
um
immediately i see my cinema 4d file
is needs to be updated so let's go ahead
and load that up and let's make it
10 seconds
as well which would be 300 frames we'll
drag that out
there we go we'll save that jump back
into after effects here
and there we go so now i can extend it
out
so
that's what i see so i would like to see
maybe the planet just slowly rotating
i'd like to see this uh shape layer
slowly rotating
maybe a camera move will become
you know from the top here and come
resting down
or we could go side to side i don't see
any type of crazy camera move um
something like this where we have a very
powerful style frame i'd like to a lot
of times just very you know
cinematically lead into that shot
whatever that may be so
i'll try a camera move side to side or
top to bottom
so i've got my camera in here and it's
important to say that my cinema
project here my cinema file
is reading my comp camera
so it's you know defaults to cinema 4d
camera but when i extracted everything
in the design part it brought the camera
in here so i changed this to comp camera
so it reads it so now if i uh if i move
this not not everything is going to move
here but
you can see that it's reacting to the
camera so
i need to make everything else this is
going to kind of screw me a little bit
but i need to make everything else 3d to
react to the camera as well
so
uh the first thing is this texture is
probably going to throw this texture off
so what i'll do is i'll take a
screenshot
yup and you can see there it's gone
right so
i need to we talked about how the center
of the cinema scene was zero zero that
camera is also looking at that zero zero
as a center point and this texture is at
950 by 462.
so i've got my screenshot i'm going to
make this 3d and it's really jacked up
here you can see it's really close to
the camera
let's maybe rotate it
on the y so it's a little more flat
i'm also going to scale it way down here
scale it down even more
and i'm going to say i'm going to turn
off the light except lights i'm going to
turn that to off
there we go there it is
so i don't necessarily want this
landscape to react to the lights which
is why i said
turn off the light
so i'm just going to kind of line this
up i'm going to move it back on the x as
well
and adjust the z
so it doesn't have to be perfect
um
let's see here i was just scaled up just
slightly so now if i go back and i hit
my
screenshots you can see it's different
it's definitely different and if i was
spending a lot of time on this i'd
probably try and get it lined up a
little bit better
to what i originally had but you know
that's a lot of times when you go from
design into motion things aren't going
to be exact how they were in your style
frames and a lot of clients you know
don't expect now sometimes they do
expect it to be just spot on and you
have to just be aware of what your
client is expecting from you
um
but since i'm the client i don't expect
that right
so there's that's that
uh the smoke's gonna be all screwed up
as well
let's go ahead and make the ground fog
let's make it 3d as well
and we're going to zero it out
zero
zero
we're going to scale it way down
well we're going to tell it not to react
to the lights except lights off
there it is and we're going to rotate it
like so
and probably scale it up a little bit
oh something like so
and then our
side smoke back here needs to be 3d
zero zero
except lights off where are you at
scale down
maybe something like that
i don't know
and let's go ahead and animate the
rotation of
the shape layer if we rotate on the z
you can see it's rotating there
so that's cool and then we'll maybe make
it rotate i don't know 35 degrees
something like that
and if that's right rotating 35 degrees
maybe the planet is rotating as well but
maybe it's less maybe it's like
i don't know let's do the main planet
let's set a keyframe
on the h so i'll just click here
go to the end and let's make it rotate
20 degrees or so
another one and then i'm going to right
click
uh animation show f curve and you can
see that we've got ease in we've got
ease out we don't want that we want
linear which is right here
linear
so now you can see it's rotating
very slightly
save that back into after effects
and let's just preview this actually
let's go ahead and set the keyframe for
the camera i want it to stop
there but i want it to start
oh i don't know maybe
[Music]
so that's from the top what's the side
look like
i don't know maybe something like that
and then i want to bring the foreground
texture
um a little bit closer to the camera to
give it a little bit of parallax
bring it down in size just a bit
there if i move through this
not the most interesting camera move
um i'll admit
but
it might work
let me uh
turn this one on let me try and just go
straight up and down actually let's do a
push in that could be kind of
interesting
so you can see the problem here with the
texture being cut off on the side um
maybe i'll scale it back up
and i'll kind of scoot it
my arrow key here i'll scale up just a
little bit more maybe 16.5
just has to cover
and let's just push in
just playing around to position the
layering of the texture here
turn my mask let's go back to subtract
on the mask here
so i'm going to preview this and see
what it looks like
okay so immediately i can see here if i
preview this i can see that this noise
this is the glow noise and it's just way
too crazy i just don't like look great
as a still
um but in motion it looks terrible
so
i would probably uh take a look over
here let's see here glow noise amplitude
frequency
speed
so i see here spread x and spread y i'm
gonna just
i don't know if this will do it or not
i'm gonna turn it way down to like 10.
let's just see what this looks like now
okay so that's still not it
so i'm gonna undo that turn it back to
96. um gosh it's got to be here in the
noise
frequency maybe if i turn that way down
nope you can still see it moving there
undo that one
jitter frames maybe if i turn that to
zero
that seems to have done something
yeah so that works i think it uh
whatever
that did maybe if i just turn that up to
like
point one
or point zero five
so it's just very very subtle but it's
enough it's a little bit of movement
there plus that smoke behind it
gives it a little bit of life there
makes it more interesting to look at
yeah actually that's still too much i'm
going to take it to .01
and let's preview this
so now it's previewing it's looking
pretty cool i think um
something that bothers me in movement is
the the shape layer here it's too
perfect right everything else is really
moody and has this kind of
really cool vibe to it and
it's too perfect so i think what i'd do
is i'd maybe blur this a little bit
and i also want to see these planets
these two little plants i want to see
them slowly rotating too so let's do
that really quick so uh the planets be
the first thing i do easy way to do that
because i already have this
big
mama planet moving i can just take
these two planets and just parent them
underneath here so you see that they
rest underneath this and that's just by
me
just dragging
i'm gonna do that really quick here just
dragging until see how the arrow changes
to down
right here
so now it's parented under there and
they can rotate
with the planet
cool
okay so that's the simple fix for that
i'll jump back into after effects
and
[Music]
just need to blur out that shape layer
just a little bit so maybe
under blur we could do there's a lot of
different ways you could always blur
this stuff
maybe a directional blur
at like an angle kind of like this
so
just guess in here and then i'll just
turn it up
it doesn't have to be a lot just a
little bit
maybe a three
well
let's really crank it up see what this
does
uh that's cool it's too much so maybe
3.5
how's that look let's go back here to
yeah i think that that probably works so
that's with
and without
with without so just kind of makes it a
little less perfect so let me uh preview
this
and check it out
okay so here's our preview of this this
is starting to look pretty darn cool
i see a couple things i see a line here
a black line right and i see this thing
right here
boom
boom
um which tells me it's some type of
layer
um and then i also
the smoke up in here i don't really see
it
so see you can see it there
but then you don't see it there so maybe
if i turn levels back off
oh yeah that's way too much so let's
just adjust this just a little bit
i'm just messing with the gray values
here the tone so there that's much more
interesting
okay maybe just a hair more
nope too much
let's try that and then i can see this
layer right here this is what's getting
cut off so what is this
that is the ground fog
so where are we at with the ground fog
it's uh negative 3.4
so
i also look at this terrain like it
should sit more up here with the terrain
right and the train position is negative
300. well it's only at negative three so
let's go
negative
301.
it's gonna bring it way up here
now let's scale it down
and let's use our arrow keys i'm moving
it sideways
then i'm moving it up
so when i go to the beginning it's it's
cool
and
are we at the end here
that probably works too so let me uh
preview this again
and guys this is what it this is what uh
it takes to get really good looking
motion and that kind of stuff i do a ton
of previewing um i know some of you guys
have asked
in previous calls in in the community
like how
how do you make really good motion well
it's a lot of previews it's a lot of
trial and error i try things see if they
work i'm not afraid to experiment and
just see what works like right now this
now this fog or the smoke coming off
planet this may be too much like in this
frame i don't love it but in motion it
may look totally different but i don't
know unless i preview take the time to
really look at things um i could turn
down my resolution to half to really get
through this quicker but i'm going to
leave it full because i want you guys to
see how it looks
okay so here it is in motion
looking pretty cool i'm pretty happy
with this the only thing that bugs me
now let's see in motion is i feel like
these rings right here
should be a little bit darker they're
too bright
in the style frame it worked for me and
this it doesn't
so the easy way to do that
is i just want to kind of feather them
out
so i'm just going to mask on this cinema
layer
let's set it to subtract
and i'm going to feather the crap out of
it
oh maybe something like so
and then i'm just going to
re-kind of reposition that
i have to watch this planet cause if i
bring this mask up too high it's gonna
uh
make that planet disappear and i don't
want that to happen
so it's kind of interesting go to the
end
good there
so i really like the way that looks
right there so i'm going to set a
keyframe for my mask
right there and i'm going to cheat this
because this is a 3d layer and we're
moving closer but the mask stays in the
same place you can see that there
so let's bring this guy out here like
something like so
okay so here's the preview
[Music]
and i dig it
very cool so there is my uh
interpretation of the planet um we could
do some some things too like what we
learned uh lower earth excuse me we
learned about uh the rule of thirds i
could probably position this planet a
little bit more down in this area
looking at it now it's a little too
centered for me as well but that's okay
i mean things can be centered sometimes
so um but i dig the motion it's very
simple
uh it's very cinematic and it works so
that's what i've got
for you this week on tone
i hope you enjoyed this little bonus
lesson where i animated this um but this
is tone uh you're watching stylecraft
i'm cameron i'll see you guys all next
week see ya